From PRI, Public Radio International--
来自PRI，国际公共广播电台——
From PRI, Public Radio--
来自PRI，公共广播——
Public Radio--
公共广播——
Public--
公共——
Radio International.
国际广播电台。
--Radio International.
——国际广播电台。
One more time.
再来一次。
What could be more American than the person who sees something they've never done before, dreams they could do it, goes after that dream? Well, let's begin today with a woman who dreams of directing a play in the small town where she lives, a college town, somewhere below the Mason-Dixon line in the hills of Appalachia, a town which will remain, for our purposes today, unnamed.
还有什么比一个人看到从未做过的事情，梦想着能去实现它，并为此去追求它更具美国精神呢？好吧，今天我们要从一位梦想在自己居住的小镇执导一部戏剧的女性说起。那是一个大学城，位于梅森-狄克逊线以南的阿巴拉契亚山脉中，为了我们今天的目的，这个小镇的名字将保持匿名。
I don't think she had ever directed. And she claimed to have acted. And it was never really quite clear just what her credentials were. But she had managed to convince the local theater department of this college that she should direct a production of Peter Pan .
我不认为她以前执导过。她声称自己演过戏。她的资历到底是什么，从来都不太清楚。但她成功说服了这所大学当地的戏剧系，让她执导一部《彼得·潘》。
When he was in the 10th grade in 1973, Jack Hitt saw her production. And like everybody else in town, he heard about it for weeks beforehand.
1973年他上十年级时，杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）看了她的演出。就像镇上的其他人一样，他在演出前几周就听说过这件事。
Slowly but surely, you began to hear sort of rumors about this production. For example, I know that they had spent a lot of money renting these flying apparatuses out of New York. And apparently, there's, like, one company and a handful of these apparatuses. And so to get them was a major coup.
慢慢地，你肯定会开始听到关于这部戏的传言。例如，我知道他们花了很多钱从纽约租借这些飞行装置。显然，只有一家公司有少量这种装置。所以能弄到它们是一次重大壮举。
This is a story not just of a mediocre play or a terrible play. When it comes right down to it, it's not even a story about a play. This is a story about a fiasco and about what makes a fiasco. And one ingredient of many fiascos is that great, massive, heart-wrenching chaos and failure are more likely to occur when great ambition has come into play, when plans are big, expectations great, hopes at their highest.
这不仅是一个平庸剧目或糟糕剧目的故事。说到底，这甚至不是关于一部戏的故事。这是一个关于惨败的故事，关于什么造成了惨败。许多惨败的一个共同点是，当巨大的野心发挥作用时，当计划宏大、期望极高、希望处于顶峰时，大规模、令人心碎的混乱和失败就更有可能发生。
And what you have to understand is that everybody in this sort of community understood that there was certainly a sort of air of everyone reaching beyond their own grasp. Every actor was sort of in a role that was just a little too big for them. Every aspect of the set and the crew-- and rumors had cooked around. There was this huge crew. There were lots of things being painted, and--
你需要明白的是，这种社区里的每个人都知道，当时确实有一种每个人都在超越自己能力范围的气氛。每个演员扮演的角色都稍微有点难以驾驭。舞台和工作人员的每一个方面——传言到处都是。有一个庞大的工作人员团队。有很多东西正在被粉刷，而且——
See, but this, in fact, is one of the criteria for greatness, is that everyone is just about to reach just beyond their grasp, because that is when greatness can occur.
你看，但实际上，这是伟大的标准之一，就是每个人都即将达到他们能力范围之外，因为那是伟大可能发生的时候。
That's right. That's right. And maybe greatness could have occurred.
没错。没错。也许伟大本可能发生。
Well, today on our program, what happens when greatness does not occur. What happens, in fact, when fumble leads to error, leads to mishap, and before you know it, you have left the realm of ordinary mistake and chaos, and you have entered into the more ethereal, specialized realm of fiasco. Today's show, Fiascoes, a philosophical inquiry-- perhaps the first ever, as far as we know-- into what makes a fiasco, what takes our ordinary lives that extra distance into fiasco.
好吧，今天在我们的节目中，当伟大没有发生时会怎样。事实上，当失误导致错误，导致事故，在你意识到之前，你已经离开了普通错误和混乱的领域，进入了一个更空灵、专门的惨败领域。今天的节目《惨败》，是一个哲学探讨——据我们所知，也许是第一次——关于什么造就了惨败，是什么让我们平凡的生活向惨败又迈进了一步。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today's program in four acts. Act One, Opening Night. Act Two, a fiasco involving a village, marauding Visigoths, a 1,900-pound brass cauldron, and some oil. Don't even ask. Act Three, Car Wars, the true story of how putting NPR's show Car Talk on the air in Wisconsin led not just to hundreds of angry letters from listeners, not just to a protest rally, not just to a monthly newsletter devoted to the scandal, but eventually, a state audit and state hearings by the legislature. Act Four, Fiascoes as a Force for Good in this World.
好吧，来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天的节目分为四幕。第一幕，首演之夜。第二幕，一场涉及一个村庄、掠夺成性的西哥特人、一口1900磅重黄铜大锅和一些油的惨败。别问了。第三幕，汽车大战，一个真实的故事，讲述威斯康星州播出NPR的《卡车谈话》（Car Talk）节目如何导致了不仅数百封听众的愤怒信件，不仅一场抗议集会，不仅一份专门针对丑闻的月刊，最终还导致了州审计和立法机构的州听证会。第四幕，惨败作为这个世界的一种向善力量。
We begin our show with this true fable of Peter Pan in Act One, Opening Night.
我们以第一幕《首演之夜》中关于彼得·潘的真实寓言开始我们的节目。
Opening night comes. And almost everybody in the area, in the 10-mile radius of this theater, knows somebody in this production. So the place is pretty much packed. And I don't know if you remember the opening moment of Peter Pan, but it's the three little kids, sleeping in their bed. And Peter Pan comes flying in the window. And in this particular production, there's a big bed with all the three kids in it. And off to the left, I remember, is a big, huge wardrobe. And there's a large window there and a little bureau.
首演之夜到了。这个剧院方圆10英里内的几乎每个人都认识参与这部作品的人。所以地方基本上坐满了。我不知道你是否还记得《彼得·潘》的开场，是三个小孩子睡在床上。然后彼得·潘飞进窗户。在这个特定的版本中，有一张大床，三个孩子都在上面。我记得在左边，是一个巨大的大衣柜。那里有一扇大窗户和一个小梳妆台。
And Peter Pan comes in and has the little speech where he says, "Anybody can fly. Why, with just a little magic dust, one can fly." And Peter Pan sprinkles this magic dust in the air. And sure enough, the kids suddenly just lurch into the air. And it becomes clear right away that the people that they've hired to run these flying apparatuses really aren't quite clear on how they actually work. So instead of the kids sailing gracefully to and fro, they sort of hang in the air like puppets, just dangling there and getting jerked up an inch or two or back and forth. And they--
彼得·潘进来说了那段小演说：“任何人都能飞。只要撒一点魔法粉末，人就能飞。”彼得·潘把魔法粉末洒在空中。果然，孩子们突然就冲向了空中。很明显，他们雇来操作这些飞行装置的人根本不清楚它们是如何工作的。所以孩子们不是优雅地来回飘动，而是像木偶一样挂在空中，就在那里摇晃，被猛地向上拉一两英寸，或者来回晃动。他们——
And then, sometimes, they're just stationary, just--
然后，有时他们只是静止不动，只是——
Yeah, just hanging there like a spider. And then, several of them start to circumscribe these circles in the air, where it's clear that the people running the machines have just set them off on these kind of oval courses that spiral farther and farther out. And if you're sitting in the audience, there was clearly a sense of fear on the faces of these people.
是的，就像蜘蛛一样挂在那里。然后，他们中的几个人开始在空中划圆圈，很明显，操作机器的人只是把他们设置在这些螺旋向外扩展的椭圆形路线上。如果你坐在观众席上，可以明显感觉到这些人脸上的恐惧。
Of the actors.
演员们的恐惧。
The actors. The actors, actually, you could sense their lack of confidence, shall we say, in the people running the machines in the back. So they--
演员们。演员们，事实上，你可以感觉到他们对后面操作机器的人缺乏信心。所以他们——
Wait, wait. And the audience reaction to this point is just-- are they laughing?
等等，等等。观众对这一点的反应只是——他们在笑吗？
No one is laughing. One of the great things about audiences, especially in a live theater production, is that they're very forgiving. They want the show to work. And so everyone is sort of gripping their chair a little tightly. We feel for them. They're up there. They're embarrassing themselves for us.
没人笑。观众的伟大之处之一，特别是在现场戏剧制作中，是他们非常宽容。他们希望演出成功。所以每个人都紧紧地抓着椅子。我们为他们感到难过。他们在那上面。他们为了我们而让自己难堪。
We identify with them.
我们与他们感同身受。
Right.
对。
We are become them.
我们变成了他们。
And so the audience, I think, was very forgiving and very understanding of this moment. But there was one moment in this first opening scene that kind of put the audience on notice. And that's when, as the kids are jerking up and down and swinging back and forth and sort of going around these ovals, at one point, the littlest one, the little boy, is being flung around a little too hard.
所以我认为观众对这一刻非常宽容，非常理解。但在第一场开场戏中有一个时刻让观众意识到了问题。那就是当孩子们上下猛拉、左右摇摆、绕着这些椭圆形飞行时，有一次，最小的那个小男孩被甩得太厉害了。
Well, he has the least mass to resist whatever the machinery is doing to him.
嗯，他抵御机器对他所做的一切的质量最轻。
Right.
对。
OK, so and?
好的，那么，然后呢？
And so he's flying around in this circle. And the audience sort of sees this coming. And there's a real sense of pain and gripping of the chair and white knuckle-ness as the kid suddenly does just an enormous splat into the wardrobe. And it's clear that he's hurt. And he comes off of it a little dazed. And then, of course, he's jerked up in the air a little bit, and often, a little too high, so that he's suddenly in the workings. He's sort of left the stage itself. He's now up there with the lights. And then all of a sudden, he's just sort of-- suddenly, he would just plummet back down to the stage and be caught up just before he hit the floor.
所以他在这个圆圈里飞着。观众们有点预感到了。当那个孩子突然一头撞进大衣柜时，有一种真正的痛苦感、紧抓椅子的感觉和紧张感。很明显他受伤了。他晃晃悠悠地下来了。然后，当然，他又被向上猛拉了一点，通常拉得太高，以至于他突然进了机关。他脱离了舞台本身。他现在在那上面和灯光在一起。然后突然之间，他就像——突然，他会径直摔回舞台，在撞到地板前的一刻被接住。
And it was hard to watch, because, as you can tell, it's an incredibly funny moment. But like I said, the audience was still in this very forgiving mode. And no one said a word. We just all sat there, holding our breath. And there's that weird tension of being in the audience, thinking, oh. Oh my goodness. They have gotten off to a very bad start. Oh, this is not good. And we feel for them.
观看这一幕很难受，因为如你所见，这是一个极其滑稽的时刻。但正如我所说，观众仍然处于这种非常宽容的模式。没有人说一句话。我们就那样坐着，屏住呼吸。有一种身处观众席的奇怪紧张感，心想，噢。天哪。他们开局非常糟糕。噢，这可不好。我们为他们感到难过。
May I just interrupt for just a moment, just to say, now, at this point-- because after all, we are not just joined here together on the radio, you and I, today, to laugh at the foibles of the unfortunate. No, no. We're here to enumerate the qualities of a fiasco. At this point, we are not yet in the territory of fiasco.
我能打断一下吗？仅仅说一句，现在，在这一点上——因为毕竟，你和我今天聚在广播里，不是为了嘲笑不幸者的怪癖。不，不。我们在这里是为了列举惨败的特质。在这一点上，我们还没有进入惨败的领域。
No. No, because, like I say, audiences are forgiving. One or two mistakes, even big ones like this, they're going to let that ride.
不。不，因为就像我说的，观众是宽容的。一两个错误，即使是像这样的大错误，他们也会放过。
Yes, they are.
是的，他们会。
We did. We did. We were very good.
我们放过了。我们放过了。我们表现得很好。
So we are not yet at fiasco. We are at a sort of normal level of mishap.
所以我们还没有到惨败。我们处于一种正常的事故水平。
Right. What happens immediately after this, they disappear to Never Never Land. And if you remember, the stage goes dark. And then, when the lights come up, there's Captain Hook. And he's giving his first opening soliloquy about how evil he is and what a menace he is and how we harms people and hates children, and it's all that good stuff. And so Captain Hook is out there. And he looks great. He's got one of those big old fat hats and this great hook and these wild looking boots and everything.
对。在此之后立即发生的是，他们消失到了梦幻岛。如果你还记得，舞台变黑了。然后，当灯光亮起，虎克船长出现了。他正在做他的第一次开场独白，讲述他是多么邪恶，他是一个多么大的威胁，他如何伤害他人，憎恨孩子，以及所有这些好东西。所以虎克船长在那里。他看起来棒极了。他戴着那些大帽子，有那个很棒的钩子，还有这些看起来很狂野的靴子等等。
And people are feeling more confident. Something's happening--
人们感觉更有信心了。发生了什么——
It's a good sign. It's a good sign. And he's in charge. This guy, he's got a bad mustache. And he is certainly evil. And the audience is totally in his pocket. He's speaking away and gesturing wildly and going on and on about how bad he is. And then, at a certain point, as he gestures, his hook and the entire black casing up to his elbow flings off of his hand and flies into the audience and punches an old lady in the gut. And now--
这是个好兆头。这是个好兆头。而且他掌控着局面。这家伙，他有一撇坏胡子。而且他确实很邪恶。观众完全被他吸引了。他滔滔不绝地讲着，疯狂地打着手势，不停地说他有多坏。然后，在某个点上，当他做手势时，他的钩子和一直到手肘的整个黑色外壳从他手上甩了出去，飞进观众席，重重打了一个老太太的肚子。现在——
He is bad.
他很坏。
He's very bad. He had the worst ad lib I've ever heard. What do you say at that point? Because, of course, his hand is now nakedly exposed to the audience.
他非常坏。他说了我听过的最糟糕的即兴台词。那种情况下你能说什么？因为，当然，他的手现在赤裸裸地暴露在观众面前。
A tough moment for any actor. If the very premise of your character is that you have a hook, your name is Captain Hook, literally, all that's going to happen for the rest of the show is people are going to refer to you by that hook, your entire motivation as a character is the fact that your arm was eaten off by an alligator and that you have to have a hook.
对任何演员来说都是艰难的时刻。如果你角色的前提是你有一个钩子，你的名字叫虎克船长，字面意思就是这样，余下演出中会发生的一切就是人们会用那个钩子来称呼你，你作为角色的全部动机就是你的手臂被鳄鱼吃掉了，你必须有一个钩子。
The entire plot stems from that fact.
整个情节都源于那个事实。
Right.
对。
And now, suddenly, you have no hook.
现在，突然间，你没有钩子了。
In fact, you have five fingers on a hand.
实际上，你有一只五根手指的手。
As if a miracle by the Lord.
好像上帝创造的奇迹。
Captain Hook said, "You know, they just don't make those hooks like they used to." That was actually the ad lib. I will never forget. Then the lights come up, and we are in Never Never Land.
虎克船长说：“你知道，他们就是不再像以前那样制造钩子了。”那实际上是他的即兴台词。我永远不会忘记。然后灯光亮起，我们身处梦幻岛。
In Act Two.
在第二幕。
Yeah, this is, like, Act Two. And Captain Hook might have stood in front of the set, but you didn't really see it, because he spoke from shadow. And now the lights come up. And this is supposed to be a very dramatic moment. The rumors of all this crew and the painting and everything that was going on and all this construction all worked towards this one moment. Because when the lights came up, here was Never Never Land, this sort of psychedelic set. There were papier-mache mushrooms everywhere of different sizes. It was absolutely wonderful and surreal. And there's nobody there. And then, from the upper rafters of stage right, suddenly, the kids and Peter Pan appear.
是的，这就像第二幕。虎克船长可能站在布景前，但你没有真正看到它，因为他是在阴影中说话的。现在灯光亮起。这本该是一个非常戏剧性的时刻。关于所有这些工作人员和绘画以及所有正在进行的建设的所有传言都指向了这一刻。因为当灯光亮起时，这就是梦幻岛，这种迷幻的布景。到处都是不同大小的纸糊蘑菇。它绝对美妙而超现实。那里没人。然后，从舞台右侧上方的椽子中，孩子们和彼得·潘突然出现。
Flying.
飞着。
Flying. They're flying. And their landing occurs rather rapidly, at an angle of about 45 degrees to the stage. They come down basically like, I don't know, lead sinkers on a line, and crash to the floor, and then are just dragged across the floor like mops and wipe out all of the mushrooms.
飞着。他们正在飞。他们的着陆相当迅速，以大约45度的角度撞向舞台。他们基本上像钓鱼线上的铅坠一样下来，撞向地板，然后像拖把一样在地上拖行，摧毁了所有的蘑菇。
And so now, have we arrived at a turning point in our fiasco?
那么现在，我们到达了惨败的转折点了吗？
Yeah. Yeah, it's clear now that the audience is giving way. Something has been lost. Some sense of decorum, that little bit of forgiveness that the audience has for the actors--
是的。是的，现在很清楚观众正在屈服。某种东西失去了。某种礼仪感，观众对演员的那一点宽容——
And empathy.
还有同理心。
--and empathy, it's beginning to dissipate. Well, there was a split in the audience. The younger people, who were the least forgiving, they started to go first. OK, so the high school students, a couple of college students, maybe, they started to laugh out loud. And I'll be honest, Ira, I might have been one of those first people to laugh. I was in the 10th grade. It was hard to not laugh at this thing. But then, whatever restraint that the audience had, it just evaporated at this point, because there were a number of things that happened in quick succession that just made it impossible to hold any sense of decorum.
——还有同理心，它开始消散。好吧，观众分成了两派。年轻人，最不宽容的一派，首先开始（发难）。好的，所以高中生，几个大学生，也许，他们开始大声笑出来。说实话，艾拉，我可能是那些首先笑的人之一。我当时上十年级。很难不嘲笑这个东西。但随后，观众所拥有的任何克制，在这一点上都蒸发了，因为发生了一系列事情，使得保持任何礼仪感变得不可能。
Which are?
是哪些事情？
For example, Tinker Bell appears for the first time around this moment. And Tinker Bell is, essentially, a light bulb on an extension cord.
例如，小叮当（Tinker Bell）在大约这个时刻第一次出现。而小叮当，本质上，是一个接在延长线上的灯泡。
What?
什么？
Yeah. And this was the director's idea of being raw, being very modern. Tinker Bell was just going to be this literal light bulb, dangling from an extension cord.
是的。这就是导演认为的原始、非常现代的想法。小叮当只是这个字面上的灯泡，悬挂在延长线上。
Whereas, in other productions, what they'll do is that someone will shine a light.
而在其他制作中，他们会做的是有人照一束光。
Shine a light, or they'll just--
照一束光，或者他们只是——
A beam of focused light. And then that pinprick of light is supposed to be Tinker Bell.
一束聚焦的光。然后那一丁点光被认为是小叮当。
That's right. Or something like that. Or nothing at all, and people just address the invisible sprite. Well, that did not happen in this case. This bulb comes just dangling down and sort of hangs around this naked light bulb--
没错。或者类似的东西。或者什么都没有，人们只是对着看不见的精灵说话。好吧，这种情况并没有发生。这个灯泡只是晃荡着下来，并在那个赤裸裸的灯泡周围晃荡——
A bare light bulb?
一个光秃秃的灯泡？
--just hangs around. And people are talking to it. And I think Tinker Bell must have had an appearance in the first act. But it was somewhere in here that people just started laughing at this. Then, another thing that happened was, later on in this scene, if you remember, Wendy gets trapped on an island. And she spots a kite that's flying by. And she's supposed to grab it and attach it to her back and fly off. Well, of course, the kite is attached to the flying apparatus line. And it gets closer and closer to her. She's standing on this little papier-mache hill.
——只是晃荡着。人们在对着它说话。我想小叮当一定在第一幕中出现过。但就在这里，人们开始嘲笑这个。然后，另一件发生的事情是，在这场戏的后面，如果你还记得，温迪被困在岛上。她发现了一只飘过的风筝。她本应该抓住它并把它系在背上飞走。好吧，当然，风筝系在飞行装置的线上。它越来越靠近她。她站在这个纸糊的小山上。
But the flying apparatus people can't quite get it close enough to her to reach. So she has to step out into the waters, that she's just told us is filled with crocodiles, to grab it. She finally gets the kite. And when she yanks on it, it pops off the flying apparatus. And the hook goes zinging up into the lights and catches. So now, there is this big loop of wire hanging in front of the stage. And there's Wendy, holding the kite. And she ad libbed as best she could, as I remember. She said, "On second thought, maybe I can swim." And with that, she walked off the stage, sort of motioning her arms like you would do the "swim," the dance, in 1965.
但操作飞行装置的人无法把它弄得足够靠近让她够到。所以她必须走进水里——她刚才告诉我们那里充满了鳄鱼——去抓住它。她终于拿到了风筝。当她猛地一拉时，它从飞行装置上弹开了。钩子嗖地一声飞进灯光里并被卡住了。所以现在，舞台前挂着一个大大的钢丝圈。温迪手里拿着风筝。据我记得，她尽可能地即兴表演了。她说：“转念一想，也许我会游泳。”说着，她走下舞台，手臂做出游泳的动作，就像1965年的那种舞步。
So she does that. At this point, the audience-- the actors are just falling apart. They are so frightened of the audience. There are just belly laughs rolling up to the stage from the audience. People are howling with laughter at every mistake. And now, any small mistake just takes on these-- any instigation for laughter is just enough for this audience. And now, the old people have given it up. Everyone has quit being nice. Now, there's just this kind of frightening roar that comes from the audience every time there's a mistake.
所以她做了那个动作。在这一点上，观众——演员们彻底崩溃了。他们非常害怕观众。从观众席传来一阵阵大笑，滚向舞台。人们对每一个错误都笑得前仰后合。现在，任何小错误都会导致这些——任何引起笑声的原因都足以让这些观众爆发。现在，老人们已经放弃了。每个人都停止了礼貌。现在，每次出现错误时，观众都会发出一种可怕的咆哮。
Well, what happened? At some point, the audience turned and realized, oh wait, I realize what's going on here. This is a fiasco.
好吧，发生了什么？在某个点上，观众转过头来意识到，噢等等，我意识到这里发生了什么。这是一场惨败。
Yeah, this is a fiasco. And what's really interesting about a fiasco is that, once it starts to tumble down, the audience wants to push it further along.
是的，这是一场惨败。关于惨败，最有趣的是，一旦它开始崩溃，观众就想把它推得更远。
Oh, they get hungry for more fiasco.
噢，他们渴望更多的惨败。
Oh, yeah.
噢，是的。
If the play proceeded perfectly, they would be disappointed.
如果这出戏进行得完美，他们会感到失望。
Oh, it would have been a grave disappointment had there not been just one more mistake after another, one more embarrassment after another. Now, the reason they're there is to chronicle these embarrassments. This is why I have remembered this play for 25 years.
噢，如果不是一个接一个的错误，一个接一个的尴尬，那将是极大的失望。现在，他们在那里是为了记录这些尴尬。这就是我25年来一直记住这部戏的原因。
Towards Act Three, Ira, the director had decided that she wanted to break down the fourth wall. This was cutting edge theater, as far she was concerned.
在第三幕之前，艾拉，导演决定她想打破第四面墙。在她看来，这是尖端戏剧。
Before you do this, I just want to explain. When we say, "breaking down the fourth wall," what we mean is the wall between the actors and the audience. Usually, it's impermeable. But then, there came a point in the late '60s, early '70s, where a lot of theaters-- basically, the actors would come out into the audience.
在你做这个之前，我只想解释一下。当我们说“打破第四面墙”时，我们指的是演员和观众之间的墙。通常，它是不可渗透的。但到了60年代末、70年代初，许多剧院出现了这种情况——基本上，演员会走到观众中去。
That's right. And interact with the audience and break down that wall. So the idea being that you would get more in touch with the dramatic sense and the reality of what was happening.
没错。与观众互动并打破那堵墙。所以其想法是，你将更深入地接触到戏剧感和正在发生的现实。
Right.
对。
Anyway, so in this particular scene, what was going to happen was that the Indians were going to throw rope ladders down from the balcony and climb down these rope ladders into the audience and move among the audience in their very scary, savage way and frighten us. Anyway, I knew about this scene because my friend, David, who I went to high school with, was in it. And so when David was climbing over the top of this balcony to climb down the rope, he lost his footing and fell to the floor from the balcony, a distance of about 15 to 20 feet--
总之，在这一特定场景中，将发生的是印第安人将从阳台上扔下绳梯，顺着绳梯爬进观众席，以他们非常可怕、野蛮的方式在观众中穿行并吓唬我们。无论如何，我知道这个场景，因为我高中时的朋友大卫就在里面。所以当大卫爬过这个阳台顶端去爬绳子时，他踩空了，从阳台摔到了地板上，距离大约15到20英尺——
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
--a good fall.
——重重摔了一下。
That's horrible.
那太可怕了。
Yeah. And he landed on both of his feet and sprained both of his ankles and, of course, curled into a fetal position and began to cry. He was really, really hurt. Now, to appreciate the horrible moment that I'm now describing, also understand that it's a Friday night. We are in a college town. And there is a volunteer fire and ambulance department. And in order to summon the rescuers from wherever they are, an alarm is sounded that can be heard for five miles. That alarm is located right over this theater.
是的。他双脚着地，扭伤了双脚踝，当然，蜷缩成胎儿姿势开始哭泣。他真的、真的很痛。现在，要体会我刚才描述的可怕时刻，还要明白这是一个星期五晚上。我们在一个大学城。这里有一个志愿者消防和救护部门。为了从他们所在的任何地方召唤救援人员，会响起一个在五英里外都能听到的警报。那个警报就在这个剧院上方。
So the alarm goes off, OK? This is an air raid siren. It is so loud, you can put your fingers in you ear and it's still hurting your ears. We're right under it. It can be heard for five miles.
所以警报响了，好吗？这是一个空袭警报。声音大得你把手指塞进耳朵里它仍然会伤害你的耳朵。我们就在它下面。它在五英里外都能听到。
And then, of course, three minutes later, busting through the door of the theater are these 15 firemen, who are in boots, hats. They've got hoses. They don't know what it is. All they know is that they've been sent out on a call. And to add to the chaos, the director, of course, has flogged the actors that the show must go on.
然后，当然，三分钟后，冲进剧院门的是这15个消防员，他们穿着靴子，戴着帽子。他们拿着软管。他们不知道发生了什么。他们只知道他们被派去执行任务。为了增加混乱，导演当然一直在鞭策演员，演出必须继续进行。
No matter what.
无论如何。
No matter what. So while all of this is happening-- and several people are attending to David. And other people have just now decided that, since the firemen are here, he's going to be fine. They can start laughing. And now, the audience has just completely lost control. People are standing up in their seats and shouting for more. They want blood. At this point, people are actually injured in the production. And they want more. Somehow, that's how this entire play ended.
无论如何。所以当这一切发生时——几个人正在照顾大卫。其他人只是因为消防员在这里而觉得他会没事的。他们可以开始笑了。现在，观众已经彻底失去控制。人们站在座位上大喊要求更多。他们想要血。在这一点上，制作中实际上有人受伤了。他们还想要更多。不知何故，整部戏就是这样结束的。
What's interesting about this as a fiasco, I feel like the thing that it makes me understand about fiascos, is that the fiasco itself is an altered state. That is, all the normal rules are off. You have left the normal rules of how the audience is going to interact with the actors.
我觉得作为一场惨败，关于它最有趣的是，它让我理解了关于惨败的一点，即惨败本身是一种改变的状态。也就是说，所有正常的规则都失效了。你已经离开了观众将如何与演员互动的正常规则。
Right. I've never seen a production like this. And I've never seen an audience collapse like this.
对。我从未见过这样的制作。我也从未见过观众像这样崩溃。
See, but I wonder, when you think about what people go to theater for, what kind of release people want, people want an experience that will take them out of themselves. We all want an experience that will take us out of ourselves and into another place and another reality. And it sounds like this production-- even though it was a fiasco, in fact, because it was a fiasco-- was more successful at that than any conventional play could be.
看，但我怀疑，当你思考人们为什么去剧院，人们想要什么样的释放时，人们想要一种能让他们摆脱自我的体验。我们都想要一种能让我们摆脱自我，进入另一个地方和另一个现实的体验。听起来这部作品——即使它是一场惨败，事实上，因为它是惨败——比任何传统戏剧都更成功地做到了这一点。
Well, see, I have to disagree with you there. See, I think the old theater critics, the ancients, would say that the reason you go to the theater to see a great production is to be, I think the word they used to use is "transported." The idea being that you would be lifted away from your animal nature and into these higher, more spiritual realms, or get in touch with these greater, tragic emotions, right? But of course, what happened here was the exact opposite. We got transported directly in touch with our animal being.
嗯，你看，我不得不在这里不同意你的观点。你看，我认为古代的戏剧评论家，古人们，会说你去看伟大制作的剧院的原因是——我想他们使用的词是“被感化（transported）”。其想法是，你将被从你的动物本性中提升出来，进入这些更高、更精神的境界，或者接触到这些更伟大的悲剧性情感，对吧？但当然，这里发生的事情恰恰相反。我们被直接带到了与我们的动物本质接触的地方。
Our baser selves.
我们的低级自我。
Right. But you know, that's almost as rare, if not more so, than a great production.
对。但你知道，这几乎和一场伟大的制作一样罕见，如果不是更罕见的话。
[MUSIC - "I WON'T GROW UP" BY RICKIE LEE JONES]
[音乐 - 瑞基·李·琼斯（Rickie Lee Jones）的《我不长大》（I WON'T GROW UP）]
Act Two, What We Wanted to Do. With some fiascos, all social order breaks down. With others, a thing that you're trying to create simply refuses to be created. And this next fiasco falls into that second category. Ron Carlson wrote this story. Jeff Dorchen reads it.
第二幕，我们想做的事。对于一些惨败，所有的社会秩序都会崩溃。对于另一些，你试图创造的东西只是拒绝被创造。接下来的这个惨败属于第二类。罗恩·卡尔森（Ron Carlson）写了这个故事。杰夫·多琴（Jeff Dorchen）朗读它。
What we wanted to do was spill boiling oil onto the heads of our enemies as they attempted to bang down the gates of our village. But as everyone now knows, we had some problems, primarily technical problems, that prevented us from doing what we wanted to do the way we had hoped to do it. What we're asking for today is another chance. There has been so much media attention to this boiling oil issue that it is time to clear the air. There's a great deal of pressure to dismantle the system we have in place and bring the oil down off the roof. This would be a mistake.
我们想做的是，在我们的敌人在试图撞开我们村庄大门时，向他们的头上倾倒沸油。但正如现在每个人都知道的那样，我们遇到了一些问题，主要是技术问题，阻止了我们按照希望的方式去做我们想做的事。我们今天要求的是再给一次机会。关于沸油问题，媒体关注度太高了，现在是澄清事实的时候了。要求拆除我们现有的系统并将油从屋顶拿下来的压力很大。这将是一个错误。
Yes, there were problems last month during the Visigoth raid. But as I will note, these are easily remedied. From its inception, I have been intimately involved with the boiling oil project-- research, development, physical deployment. I also happened to be team leader on the roof last month when we had occasion to try the system during the Visigoth attack, about which so much has been written.
是的，上个月在西哥特人袭击期间确实出现了问题。但我会指出，这些很容易补救。从一开始，我就深入参与了沸油项目——研究、开发、物理部署。上个月当我们在西哥特人袭击期间有机会尝试该系统时，我正好是屋顶上的组长，关于这一点已经写了很多文章。
First, the very concept of oil on the roof upset many of our villagers. Granted, it is exotic. But all great ideas seem strange at first. When our researchers realized we could position a cauldron 200 feet directly above our main portals, they began to see the possibilities of the greatest strategic defense system in the history of mankind. But at every turn, we've met problems that our researchers could not, despite their intelligence and intuition, have foreseen.
首先，屋顶上有油的概念让我们的许多村民感到不安。诚然，这很异国情调。但所有伟大的想法起初看起来都很奇怪。当我们的研究人员意识到我们可以将一口大锅放置在直接位于我们主入口上方200英尺处时，他们开始看到人类历史上最伟大的战略防御系统的可能性。但在每一个转折点，我们都遇到了我们的研究人员，尽管有他们的智慧和直觉，也无法预见的问题。
For instance, how were we to get a 1,900-pound brass cauldron onto the roof? In the end, the cauldron was raised to the roof by means of a custom designed net and petard under less than ideal conditions. The Retrogoths and the Nilogoths plundered our village almost incessantly during the cauldron's four month ascent.
例如，我们如何将一口1900磅重的黄铜大锅弄到屋顶上？最后，大锅是在不太理想的条件下，通过定制设计的网和迫击炮被吊到屋顶上的。在大锅上升的四个月里，Retrogoths和Nilogoths几乎不断地洗劫我们的村庄。
The cauldron's arrival on the roof was quite a moment. I remember it well. We stood by that gleaming symbol of our impending safety, a bright brass beacon to the world that we were not going to take it anymore. The wind carried up to us the cries of villagers being carried away by either the Maxigoths or the Minigoths. But there we stood. And as I felt the wind in my hair and watched the sporadic procession of home furnishings being carried out of our violated gates, I knew we were perched on the edge of a new epoch.
大锅到达屋顶是一个重要的时刻。我记得很清楚。我们站在那个即将到来的安全的闪亮象征旁边，一个向世界发出的明亮黄铜灯塔，表明我们不会再忍受了。风把被Maxigoths或Minigoths带走的村民的哭声传给我们。但我们站在那里。当我感觉到头发里的风，看着从我们被践踏的大门里搬走的家居用品的零星队伍时，我知道我们正处于一个新时代的边缘。
Well, there was some excitement. We began at once. We started a fire under the cauldron. And we knew we would all soon be safe. At that point, I made a mistake, which I now readily admit. In the utter ebullience of the moment, I called down. I did not scream maniacally, as was reported. I called down that it would not be long. And I probably shouldn't have, because it may have led some of our citizenry to lower their guard. It was a mistake. I admit it.
好吧，有一些兴奋。我们立刻开始了。我们在大锅下生火。我们知道我们很快都会安全。在那一点上，我犯了一个错误，我现在欣然承认。在那一刻的彻底欢呼中，我向下面喊话。我没有像报道的那样疯狂尖叫。我向下喊话，说不会太久了。我可能不应该这样做，因为它可能导致我们的一些市民降低了警惕。这是一个错误。我承认。
There were, as we found out almost immediately, still some bugs to be worked out of the program. For instance, there had never been a fire on top of the entry tower before. And yes, as everyone is aware, we had to spend more time than we really wanted containing the blaze, fueled as it was by the fresh high winds and the tower's wooden shingles. I hasten to add that the damage was moderate, as moderate as a four hour fire could be.
正如我们几乎立即发现的那样，程序中仍然有一些漏洞需要解决。例如，之前入口塔顶上从未起过火。而且是的，正如每个人都知道的那样，我们不得不花费比我们真正想要的更多的时间来控制大火，因为火势受到新鲜大风和塔楼木瓦的助长。我急忙补充说，损害是适度的，像一场四小时的大火一样适度。
But throughout this relentless series of setbacks, pitfalls, and rooftop fires, there has been a hard core of us absolutely dedicated to doing what we wanted to do, to splash scalding oil onto intruders as they pried or battered, yet again, at our old damaged gates. It was a little fire on the rooftop. It was of no consequence, a fribble, a tiny obstacle to be stepped over with an easy stride. Were we tired? Were we dirty? Were some of us burned and cranky? No matter. We were committed.
但在这这一连串无情的挫折、陷阱和屋顶火灾中，我们有一群核心人员绝对致力于做我们想做的事，向入侵者喷洒滚烫的油，当他们再次撬动或猛撞我们受损的老大门时。屋顶上有一点小火。这无关紧要，一个琐事，一个可以轻松迈过的小障碍。我们累吗？我们脏吗？我们当中有些人被烧伤了吗？没关系。我们承诺了。
And so the next day, the first quiet day we'd had in this village in months, that same sooty cadre stood in the warm ashes high above the entry steps and tried again. We knew, as we know right now, that our enemies are manifold and voracious and generally rude and persistent. And we wanted to be ready. But tell me this. Where does one find out how soon before an enemy attack to put the oil on to boil? Does anyone know? Let me assure you, it is not in any book. We were writing the book.
所以第二天，我们几个月来在村子里最安静的一天，那群满身煤灰的人站在入口台阶上方温暖的灰烬中，再次尝试。我们知道，正如我们现在所知道的那样，我们的敌人是多方面的、贪婪的，而且通常是粗鲁和执着的。我们想做好准备。但告诉我这个。在敌袭前多久开始煮油？有人知道吗？让我向你保证，没有任何书里有记载。我们在写书。
We were vigilant. We squinted at the horizon all day long. And when we first saw the dust in the foothills, we fired our cauldron, using wood that had been elevated through the night in woven baskets. Even speaking about it here today, I can feel the excitement stirring in my heart. The orange flames licked the sides of the brass container hungrily, as if in concert with our own desperate desire for security and revenge. In the distance, I could see the phalanx of Visigoths marching toward us like a warship through a sea of dust. In my soul, I pitied them and the end toward which they so steadfastly hastened. They seemed the very incarnation of mistake, their dreams of a day abusing our friends and families and of petty arson and lewd public behavior about to be extinguished in one gorgeous wash of searing oil. I was beside myself.
我们保持警惕。我们整天眯着眼睛看着地平线。当我们第一次在山脚下看到灰尘时，我们点燃了大锅，使用了整夜在编织篮中提升上来的木头。即使今天在这里谈论它，我依然能感觉到兴奋在心中激荡。橙色的火焰贪婪地舔着黄铜容器的侧面，仿佛在配合我们自己对安全和复仇的绝望渴望。在远处，我可以看到一群西哥特人像战舰穿过灰尘之海一样向我们进军。在灵魂深处，我怜悯他们，以及他们坚定不移地奔向的结局。他们似乎是错误的化身，他们那天虐待我们的朋友和家人以及琐碎纵火和淫秽公共行为的梦想即将在那一股华丽的灼热油浪中熄灭。我无法自已。
It is important to know now that everyone on the roof that day exhibited orderly and methodical behavior. There was no wild screaming or cursing or even the kind of sarcastic chuckling you might expect in those about to enjoy a well deserved and long delayed victory. The problems of the day were not attributable to inappropriate deportment. My staff was good.
现在重要的是要知道，那天屋顶上的每个人都表现出了有序和有条理的行为。没有疯狂的尖叫或咒骂，甚至没有你可能期望在那些即将享受当之无愧和姗姗来迟的胜利的人们中出现的讽刺轻笑。当天的麻烦不能归因于不适当的举止。我的员工很好。
It was when the Visigoths had approached close enough that we could see their cruel eyes and we could read their savage and misspelled tattoos that I realized our error. At that time, I put my hand on the smooth side of our beautiful cauldron and found it only vaguely warm, lukewarm, tepid. We had not known then what we now know. We need to put the oil on sooner. It was my decision, and my decision alone, to do what we did, and that was to pour the warm oil on our enemies as they milled about the front gates, hammering at it with their truncheons.
就在西哥特人靠近到我们可以看到他们残酷的眼睛，我们可以读出他们野蛮且拼写错误的纹身时，我意识到我们的错误。当时，我把手放在我们美丽大锅的光滑侧面上，发现它只是隐约温暖，温热，不温不火。我们当时不知道我们现在所知道的事情。我们需要更早地把油放上去。这是我的决定，而且是我一个人的决定，去做我们所做的事情，那就是把温油倒在我们正在前门附近徘徊的敌人身上，他们正用警棍敲打着大门。
Now, this is where my report diverges from so many of the popular accounts. We have heard it said that the warm oil served as a stimulant to the attack that followed, the attack I alluded to earlier, in which the criminal activity seemed even more animated than usual in the minds of some of our townspeople. Let me say first, I was an eyewitness. I gave the order to pour the oil, and I witnessed its descent. I am happy and proud to report that the oil hit its target with an accuracy and completeness I could have only dreamed of. We got them all. There was oil everywhere. We soaked them. We coated them. We covered them with a lustrous layer of oil. Unfortunately, as everyone knows, it was only warm.
现在，这是我的报告与许多流行记叙分歧的地方。我们听说有人说温油激发了随后的袭击，即我之前提到的袭击，在一些镇民的心中，犯罪活动似乎比平时更加活跃。让我先说，我是目击者。我下令倒油，我目睹了它的下降。我很高兴也很自豪地报告，油以我梦寐以求的准确性和完整性命中了目标。我们抓住了他们所有人。到处都是油。我们浸透了他们。我们覆盖了他们。我们用一层光泽的油覆盖了他们。不幸的是，正如每个人都知道的那样，它只是温的。
Their immediate reaction was also what I had hoped for, surprise and panic. This, however, lasted about one second. Then, several of them looked up into my face and began waving their fists in what I could only take as a tribute. And then, yes, they did become quite agitated anew, recommencing their assault on the weary planks of our patchwork gates. Some have said that they were on the verge of abandoning their attack before the oil was cast upon them, which I assure you is not true.
他们的直接反应也正如我所希望的那样，惊讶和恐慌。然而，这持续了大约一秒钟。然后，他们中的几个人抬头看着我的脸，开始挥舞拳头，这只能被我看作是一种致敬。然后，是的，他们确实变得相当激动，重新开始了对我们拼凑大门那疲惫木板的攻击。有些人说在油倒在他们身上之前，他们正处于放弃攻击的边缘，我可以向你保证那不是真的。
As to the attack that followed, it was no different in magnitude or intensity than any of the dozens we suffer every year. It may have seemed more odd or extreme, since the perpetrators were greasy and thereby more offensive. And they did take every stick of furniture left in the village, including the pews from the church, every chair in the great hall, and four milking stools, the last four from the dairy.
至于随后的袭击，其规模或强度与我们每年遭受的几十次袭击没有什么不同。它可能看起来更奇怪或更极端，因为作案者满身油腻，因此更具冒犯性。他们确实带走了村里剩下的所有家具，包括教堂的长椅、大会堂里的每一把椅子，以及四个挤奶凳，即乳品厂剩下的最后四个。
But I, for one, am simply tired of hearing about the slippery stain on the village steps. Yes, there is a bit of a mess. And yes, some of it seems to be permanent. My team removed what they could with salt and talc all this week. All I'll say now is watch your step as you come and go. In my mind, it's a small inconvenience to pay for a perfect weapon system.
但我，作为一个，只是厌倦了听到关于村庄台阶上的油滑污渍。是的，有点乱。是的，有些似乎是永久性的。我的团队这周用盐和滑石粉清除了他们能清除的一切。我现在唯一要说的就是进出时注意脚下。在我看来，为了一套完美的武器系统，这是一个很小的代价。
"What We Wanted to Do" is from Ron Carlson's book of short stories called Hotel Eden.
“我们想做的事”来自罗恩·卡尔森的小说集《伊甸园酒店》。
Coming up, how a friendly little radio show about cars from the fair city of Boston ended up the subject of legislative hearings in Wisconsin and other fiascos. That's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，一个关于汽车的友好小广播节目，来自波士顿这个公平的城市，最终如何成为威斯康星州立法听证会的主题，以及其他惨败。稍后，来自国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week ON our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Fiasco!, our own inquiry into the nature of what makes a fiasco, and when you have left the realm of mishap, stumble, human error, and entered the more rarefied realm of fiasco. We have arrived at Act Three, Car Wars. If you are hearing the sound of my voice right now, you probably have also heard these voices.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的各种不同类型的故事。今天的节目，《惨败！》，我们自己对造成惨败本质的探索，以及当你离开了事故、绊脚石、人为错误领域，进入更稀有的惨败领域时。我们已经到达了第三幕，汽车大战。如果你现在听到我的声音，你可能也听过这些声音。
Gee, you know, I just had a brilliant invention. People have cup holders in their cars. But the problem with a cup holder, it's frequently located in a bad spot.
哎，你知道，我刚有一个绝妙的发明。人们在车里有杯架。但杯架的问题是，它通常位于一个糟糕的位置。
I know what you're going to think of. A straw. A three-foot straw.
我知道你会想到什么。吸管。三英尺长的吸管。
A three-foot flexible straw.
三英尺长的柔性吸管。
You could even drink gasoline out of the tank if you wanted to.
如果你愿意，你甚至可以从油箱里喝汽油。
Or you could drink out of your friend's cup, too--
或者你可以喝你朋友杯子里的——
This is Car Talk . And though you may think of it as simply the friendly banter of Tom and Ray Magliozzi, Click and Clack, it is also the single most popular hour in public radio. And this story starts simply enough. Wisconsin Public Radio, a network of 14 stations in, guess which state, decided they wanted to save a few bucks. And years ago, when nearly every other public radio station in the country signed up with the most single popular show in public radio, Wisconsin public radio thought, it'll cost money. It'll cost us tens of thousands of dollars. And it's just a car show. We can do our own car show. So they did.
这是《卡车谈话》。虽然你可能认为它只是汤姆和雷·马格里奥齐（Tom and Ray Magliozzi），克里克和克拉克（Click and Clack）的友好玩笑，但它也是公共广播中单小时收听率最高的节目。这个故事开始得很简单。威斯康星州公共广播电台，一个拥有14个广播站的网络，猜猜是哪个州，决定他们想省点钱。多年前，当全国几乎所有的其他公共广播电台都签约了公共广播中最受欢迎的节目时，威斯康星州公共广播电台想，这要花钱。这要花我们数万美元。而这只是一个汽车节目。我们可以做我们自己的汽车节目。所以他们做了。
Welcome to another hour of About Cars . Lori Skelton in the studio with Matt Joseph. And later in the hour, we have a review of the 1995 Dodge Viper RT/10. And we stand to run out of adjectives for this before the hour is over. It's a stunning piece of raw, brute force.
欢迎来到又一小时的《关于汽车》。洛里·斯凯尔顿（Lori Skelton）在演播室与马特·约瑟夫（Matt Joseph）在一起。在本小时晚些时候，我们将回顾1995年的道奇Viper RT/10。在这一小时结束之前，我们恐怕会用完形容词。它是一个令人惊叹的原始、蛮力的杰作。
I think the one word we applied was "wow."
我想我们应用的一个词是“哇”。
Yeah, basically. We'll add a few others a little later--
是的，基本上。我们稍后会再加几个——
Matt Joseph's show All About Cars , was on Saturday mornings, where most public radio stations run Car Talk , the most popular show on public radio. He was the car expert. She would prompt him along, asking the questions that you or I might ask. Call-ins went into much more technical detail about engines than you ever hear from Tom and Ray. And the show started with 10 minutes of serious automotive industry news.
马特·约瑟夫的节目《关于汽车》在周六早上播出，大多数公共广播电台在那里播放《卡车谈话》，公共广播中最受欢迎的节目。他是汽车专家。她会提示他，问你或我可能会问的问题。电话拨入的内容比你从汤姆和雷那里听到的更具汽车发动机的技术细节。节目以10分钟严肃的汽车工业新闻开始。
General motors announced in Los Angeles last week that they're going to sell EV1, the impact car, which many people have seen. I've actually driven it a couple of years ago. It will be joined by a conversion of the S10--
通用汽车上周在洛杉矶宣布，他们将销售EV1，那款冲击力汽车，许多人都见过。几年前我实际上开过它。它将加入S10的改装版本——
It was a perfectly decent, solid, informative hour of radio. And while it was not the single most popular show on public radio, it got good ratings, had fans, did great in pledge drives. Matt Joseph thought he was doing everything right. Now, a fiasco can begin, like any human dispute, with a simple misunderstanding, a difference in perspective. And in this case, Matt Joseph's bosses had a completely different perspective on his show from his perspective.
这是一个非常体面、扎实、信息丰富的广播小时。虽然它不是公共广播中最受欢迎的节目，但它收视率不错，有粉丝，在筹款活动中表现出色。马特·约瑟夫以为他做的一切都是对的。现在，一场惨败可以像任何人类纠纷一样，从一个简单的误解、视角的不同开始。在这种情况下，马特·约瑟夫的老板们对他的节目的看法与他自己的看法截然不同。
Sure, he got great ratings, his bosses thought, but it could be so much more, if only he more like, well, like the most popular single show on public radio, Car Talk . They were constantly trying to get him to make his show snappier, faster paced, more of an entertainment. Matt Joseph thought they were wrong. They were always threatening to cancel him and bring in Car Talk . They wrote unpleasant memos, and there were tense meetings. And this fundamental disagreement laid the groundwork for the fiasco that followed.
当然，他有很好的收视率，老板们心想，但它本可以更好，只要他更像，嗯，像公共广播中最受欢迎的节目《卡车谈话》。他们一直在试图让他让节目更时髦、节奏更快、更具娱乐性。马特·约瑟夫认为他们错了。他们总是威胁要取消他的节目并引进《卡车谈话》。他们写了令人不快的备忘录，并举行了紧张的会议。这种根本性的分歧为随后的惨败奠定了基础。
Finally, because of a complicated deal involving Whad'Ya Know? , Michael Feldman's game show, which is produced by Wisconsin Public Radio, the price of Car Talk to Wisconsin Public Radio dropped from $33,000 to an affordable $10,000. And the network which had thought that it did not need the single most popular show on public radio looked over its shoulder at what was happening on 400 other radio stations and decided that maybe, in fact, they had been wrong. They wanted Car Talk. Joy Cardin is one of the Wisconsin Public Radio programmers behind all this.
最后，由于涉及迈克尔·费尔德曼（Michael Feldman）的游戏节目《你知道什么？》（Whad'Ya Know?）的复杂交易——该节目由威斯康星州公共广播电台制作——《卡车谈话》对威斯康星州公共广播电台的价格从33,000美元降到了10,000美元。那个认为自己不需要公共广播中最受欢迎节目的网络，回过头来看看400个其他广播电台上正在发生的事情，并决定也许，事实上，他们错了。他们想要《卡车谈话》。乔伊·卡丁（Joy Cardin）是所有这些背后的威斯康星州公共广播电台节目策划人之一。
The most recent audience research that we had showed that Car Talk is a program that works extremely well when it's paired with Whad'Ya Know? with Michael Feldman. And in fact, both programs do better. And we made the recommendation that the best place to put Car Talk would be 9 o'clock on Saturday morning, followed by Whad'Ya Know? with Michael Feldman.
我们拥有的最新观众研究显示，《卡车谈话》是一个当它与迈克尔·费尔德曼的《你知道什么？》搭配时效果极佳的节目。事实上，两个节目的表现都更好。我们建议将《卡车谈话》放在周六早上9点，后面紧接着迈克尔·费尔德曼的《你知道什么？》。
Of course, 9:00 in the morning was when All About Cars was on the air. But, says, Joy Cardin, they did not want to kill All About Cars. They simply wanted to move it to a different time.
当然，早上9点是《关于汽车》播出的时间。但是，乔伊·卡丁说，他们不想砍掉《关于汽车》。他们只是想把它搬到一个不同的时间。
We knew About Cars was a popular program. We certainly were trying to keep it on the schedule. The recommendation was to find a mutually agreeable time on Saturday afternoons.
我们知道《关于汽车》是一个受欢迎的节目。我们当然试图把它保留在时间表上。建议是找到一个周六下午双方都能接受的时间。
Did you name a specific time?
你指定了一个具体时间吗？
We started with a specific time. We started with a specific time of 3 o'clock.
我们以一个具体时间开始。我们以下午3点这个具体时间开始。
So what happened then? What was his response?
那么后来发生了什么？他的回应是什么？
His response was, absolutely not.
他的回应是，绝对不行。
Ms. Cardin said they were thinking of moving it to 3 o'clock. I said I found that unacceptable. I never said I wouldn't do it. I just said I found it unacceptable in the sense that I really didn't like it.
卡丁女士说他们考虑把它搬到3点。我说我觉得这不可接受。我从来没说过我不会做。我只是说我觉得它不可接受，因为我真的不喜欢它。
Our response to that was, "Well, is there any time on Saturday afternoon that would be agreeable to you to reschedule this program?" "No."
我们对那个的回应是，“好吧，周六下午有任何时间是你觉得可以重新安排这个节目的吗？”“没有。”
The last thing I said to them was, "I suggest we do it at 8 o' clock." They said, "We will think about it and get back to you." They got back to me by firing me. I never flatly rejected 3 o'clock. Now, if you want to ask me, would I have rejected 3 o' clock? Yes, I would have.
我对他们说的最后一件事是，“我建议我们在8点做。”他们说，“我们会考虑一下并回复你。”他们回复我的方式是解雇我。我从来没有断然拒绝3点。现在，如果你想问我，我会拒绝3点吗？是的，我会的。
Now, to understand why he would say no to 3 o'clock, you have to understand that, from Matt Joseph's perspective, this was just the latest insult from bosses who had always doubted and questioned the way he did his show. It made no sense to him, this treatment. After all, his ratings were strong. Sometimes, he was the single strongest show in their Saturday morning lineup. His show was inexpensive. It was a success. Why couldn't they be more respectful?
现在，要理解为什么他会对3点说不，你必须明白，从马特·约瑟夫的角度来看，这只是老板们对他做节目的方式总是怀疑和质疑的最新侮辱。这种对待对他来说毫无意义。毕竟，他的收视率很强。有时，他是他们周六早上节目阵容中最强的一档。他的节目很便宜。这是一个成功。为什么他们就不能更尊重一点呢？
If somebody had come to me and said, "Hey, Matt, we've got a really weak afternoon, and we think you can really help. And we're going to give you really adequate promotion, and so forth. Would you help us out with our--," if somebody had approached me that way, I certainly would have listened and probably would have agreed to it.
如果有人来对我说，“嘿，马特，我们有一个很弱的下午，我们认为你真的可以提供帮助。我们会给你足够的支持，等等。你会帮我们……”如果有人那样接近我，我肯定会听，也可能会同意。
Now, you know, one definition of a fiasco is something small and ordinary that turns into something monstrously large. And what could be smaller in this world, my friend, than simply trying to reschedule a public radio car show from the morning to the afternoon? Well after his show was canceled, 1,500 calls and letters came into Wisconsin Public Radio, demanding that Matt Joseph be put back on the air. Contributors to the network demanded $2,600 in pledges to be returned. 126 people said they would never give money to the network again. Matt Joseph started putting out a monthly newsletter about the fiasco. He organized a rally in Madison. There were editorials in local papers and letters to the editor. Against his will, he said, it became his cause.
现在，你知道，惨败的一个定义是小而普通的事情演变成了极其巨大的事情。还有什么能比试图将一个公共广播汽车节目从早上重新安排到下午更小的呢？在他节目被取消后，1,500个电话和信件打入威斯康星州公共广播电台，要求马特·约瑟夫回到广播中。网络贡献者要求退还2,600美元的承诺捐款。126人表示他们再也不会给该网络捐钱了。马特·约瑟夫开始发行一份关于这场惨败的月刊。他在麦迪逊组织了一场集会。当地报纸有社论和给编辑的信。他说，违背他的意愿，这成了他的事业。
Car Talk is like a monolith. It has crushed all of the independent car shows around the country, one by one, over the years. It just goes on like a juggernaut. We had something better. Now, there should be room for one serious show on public radio, one show that has content.
《卡车谈话》就像一个庞然大物。多年来，它一个接一个地碾压了全国各地所有的独立汽车节目。它就像一个重型推土机一样前进。我们有更好的东西。现在，公共广播中应该有严肃节目的空间，有一个有内容的节目。
Well, finally, the state of Wisconsin legislature, which gives millions each year to Wisconsin Public Radio, did a state audit investigating the matter, interviewing programmers, showing up at the offices of Wisconsin Public Radio.
嗯，最后，每年给威斯康星州公共广播电台数百万美元的威斯康星州立法机构，进行了一次调查此事的州审计，采访节目策划人，出现在威斯康星州公共广播电台的办公室。
They showed up. And two auditors did show up to go through our listener files, to see the letters that came in from listeners regarding About Cars . And we provided them with a conference room. And they went through all of the letters and counted them up, how many were for About Cars and how many were for Car Talk.
他们出现了。两名审计员确实出现了，查看了我们的听众档案，查看了听众关于《关于汽车》发来的信件。我们为他们提供了一个会议室。他们浏览了所有的信件并进行了清点，多少是支持《关于汽车》的，多少是支持《卡车谈话》的。
If you had to estimate how much time state employees, taxpayer-paid employees, had to spend and ended up spending investigating this, was it two guys for a week? How long were they on this case?
如果你必须估计一下纳税人支付的员工花了多少时间来调查此事，是两个人一周吗？他们在案子上花了多久？
It seemed to me that it went on for about three months.
在我看来，它持续了大约三个月。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
Yeah, it did. It seemed to me that it went on for many weeks. And it wasn't every day, but it was very distracting.
是的，确实。在我看来，它持续了很多周。而且不是每天都这样，但这非常令人分心。
But this was not the only use of taxpayer dollars on this urgent public matter. A joint audit committee of the state legislature held a public hearing, in which legislators and listeners criticized Wisconsin Public Radio programmers. 40 people showed up from all over the state to testify. It made headlines throughout the state. And all this over whether a car show should've been moved to the afternoon or taken off the air. Senator Robert Wirch, who co-chaired the hearing, says the citizens of Wisconsin were mad. He had no choice but to have hearings.
但这并不是纳税人的钱在这个紧急公共事务上的唯一用途。州立法机构的一个联合审计委员会举行了一场公开听证会，立法者和听众在会上批评了威斯康星州公共广播电台的策划人。全州有40人出面作证。这在全州都成了头条新闻。而这一切仅仅是因为一个汽车节目是否应该搬到下午播出或下线。共同主持听证会的罗伯特·沃奇（Robert Wirch）参议员说，威斯康星州的公民很生气。他别无选择，只能举行听证会。
Are we micromanaging the station? No. We were providing a forum for all sides to come in and discuss the matter.
我们是在对电台进行微观管理吗？不。我们是在提供一个论坛，让各方进来讨论此事。
I have to say, though, as an outsider, as somebody who doesn't live in Wisconsin, it just is so strange, the notion that the state legislature would get involved with an issue, what seems so small.
不过，作为一个局外人，作为一个不住在威斯康星州的人，我不得不说，州立法机构会参与到一个似乎如此小的问题中，这太奇怪了。
Well, this was a locally generated program in Wisconsin. And what did they bring? A network program in from Massachusetts. That has clearly angered citizens of Wisconsin.
嗯，这是一个在威斯康星州当地生成的节目。他们带来了什么？一个来自马萨诸塞集的网络节目。这显然激怒了威斯康星州的公民。
I mean, this is not unusual, I guess. We have demonstrations in just about every city that we're on in. There are people who come to the station, and they picket, and they scream, and they yell.
我的意思是，这并不罕见，我想。我们在几乎每个我们播出的城市都有示威活动。有人来到电台，他们纠察、尖叫、大喊。
Well, for some perspective on this matter, I decided to go to the top, to the men behind the single most popular hour in public radio, Click and Clack, Tom and Ray Magliozzi.
好吧，为了对这件事有一些了解，我决定去问问顶层，即公共广播中单小时收视率最高的节目背后的人，克里克和克拉克，汤姆和雷·马格里奥齐。
Since you guys weren't at the hearings to speak in your own defense, I wanted to play you a quote from State Senator Robert Wirch, who held these hearings.
既然你们没有参加听证会为自己辩护，我想给你们播放一句举行这些听证会的州参议员罗伯特·沃奇的话。
Robert Wirch?
罗伯特·沃奇？
Wirch.
沃奇（Wirch）。
沃奇。
Senator Robert Wirch of the good state of Wisconsin, who held these hearings. And I wanted to just play what he said about your show versus the local show, which was hosted by a guy named Matt Joseph, and just give you a chance to respond.
来自威斯康星州的罗伯特·沃奇参议员，他举行了这些听证会。我只是想播放他关于你们节目与那个由马特·约瑟夫主持的当地节目相比所说的话，给你们一个回应的机会。
Sure, I'd love to hear it.
当然，我很想听听。
Yeah, OK.
是的，好的。
Here we go.
开始了。
Well, when I listened to Matt Joseph, I had the feeling I was listening to an expert. And he is acknowledged by car collectors around the state as an expert. And the other one, I think, is kind of showbiz with looking for a laugh. And I can understand where the casual fan may like the laughter and camaraderie of the two guys that do the show. But on public radio, we're used to listening to people with a little more expertise.
嗯，当我听马特·约瑟夫时，我感觉我在听一位专家。他被全州的汽车收藏家公认为专家。而另一个，我认为，有点像寻找笑料的秀场。我可以理解为什么普通的粉丝可能喜欢这两个做节目的人的笑声和友情。但在公共广播中，我们习惯于听具有更多专业知识的人的声音。
Response?
回应？
Yeah. Boy, if that is not the classic definition of a stiff, I don't know what is.
是的。天哪，如果那不是僵化的经典定义，我就不知道什么是了。
Yeah, he sounds like a barrel of laughs.
是的，他听起来像一桶笑话。
Well, wouldn't you love to have coffee with him? "On public radio, we're more used to listening to more boring things than these two jerks." Well, tell him that we feel the same way about him. And I didn't enjoy listening to what he had to say, either.
好吧，你不想和他一起喝咖啡吗？“在公共广播中，我们更习惯于听比这两个笨蛋更无聊的东西。”好吧，告诉他，我们也对他有同样的看法。我也不喜欢听他要说的话。
I won't be voting him anymore.
我不会再投他票了。
Well, I don't know. Everyone has his own opinion. I don't think he's wrong about what he said.
好吧，我不知道。每个人都有自己的观点。我不认为他在所说的话上错了。
No, and I'm sure this other fellow, whom we attempted to usurp here, probably is a lot more knowledgeable, certainly more informative, than we are. Because we don't take the car business, at least on the radio, that seriously. Ira, but did anyone speak in our behalf?
不，而且我相信我们要在这里篡夺的这位同行，可能知识比我们丰富得多，肯定比我们信息丰富。因为我们不那么认真对待汽车生意，至少在广播里是这样。艾拉，但有人为我们辩护了吗？
Of course not.
当然没有。
Apparently not. No, there apparently was an entire hearing, and nobody spoke for the two of you.
显然没有。不，显然有一场完整的听证会，没有人为你们两个说话。
And nobody-- why weren't we invited to defend ourselves? I would have flown my brother out there.
而且没有人——为什么我们没有被邀请为自己辩护？我会让我兄弟飞到那里去。
In a sense, the Wisconsin car show fiasco happens on a much smaller scale whenever any show with any following is taken off any public radio station in this country. People get upset, partly, I think, because every pledge drive-- which is, what, three or four times a year on most of these stations-- listeners hear programmers like me say, "You are the 'public' in public radio." And so listeners are understandably angry, being the "public" in public radio, when a show they like is suddenly gone. But it is exactly incidents like this one in Wisconsin, and programmers' fear of incidents like this one in Wisconsin, that makes innovation so slow in most of the public radio system.
在某种意义上，当任何有追随者的节目被这个国家的任何公共广播电台撤下时，威斯康星州的汽车节目惨败都会以更小的规模发生。人们感到不安，部分是因为我认为，每次筹款活动——在大多数这些电台上，一年有三四次——听众会听到像我这样的策划人说，“你们是公共广播中的‘公共’。”所以听众在他们喜欢的节目突然消失时，作为公共广播中的“公共”，感到愤怒是可以理解的。但正是像威斯康星州发生的这种事件，以及策划人对威斯康星州这种事件的恐惧，使得大多数公共广播系统中的创新非常缓慢。
Yeah, that's it. I believe that this really has had a very chilling effect on Wisconsin Public Radio and myself, personally.
是的，就是这样。我相信这对我本人，对威斯康星州公共广播电台确实产生了非常冷淡的影响。
Joy Cardin, who spent months dealing with the Wisconsin car show fiasco, says that now she thinks twice before moving any show.
处理威斯康星州汽车节目惨败数月的乔伊·卡丁说，现在她在移动任何节目之前都会三思而后行。
And it makes you think long and hard before you make those kinds of decisions, because you don't want necessarily a public outcry or the legislature examining your every move.
在做出这些决定之前，你会想得很深，因为你不想必然引起公众的强烈抗议，或者让立法机构检查你的一举一动。
This fiasco is also a parable of bigger changes coming within the public radio system. Partly because of the success of Car Talk , there is a move to come up with lighter, more entertaining shows in the public radio system, especially for weekends. Matt Joseph's fiasco occurred partly because he represented an older style of public radio, a more informative style. After some months off the air, Matt Joseph now does his show All About Cars on a commercial station, WDTY in Madison. He's on up against Car Talk.
这场惨败也是公共广播系统内即将来临的更大变革的寓言。部分由于《卡车谈话》的成功，公共广播系统中出现了一种转向更轻松、更具娱乐性的节目的趋势，特别是在周末。马特·约瑟夫的惨败部分是因为他代表了公共广播的一种旧风格，一种更信息化的风格。在下线几个月后，马特·约瑟夫现在在麦迪逊的商业电台WDTY上做他的节目《关于汽车》。他是在与《卡车谈话》对抗。
Hey, Matt?
嘿，马特？
Yes?
是吗？
Is this over for you yet?
这事对你来说结束了吗？
Is it over yet? No. No, it will be over when the changes are made at Wisconsin Public Radio that restores that service to what it used to be, a responsive service that has things like children's programming, that has local drama, that educates students in broadcasting. These are all things that don't go on over there anymore.
结束了吗？不。不，当威斯康星州公共广播电台做出改变，恢复到以前的服务时，它才会结束，那是一种响应式服务，有儿童节目、当地戏剧、在广播中教育学生等内容。这些都是那里不再有的东西。
You're describing all these things that used to be the kinds of things that were on public radio that didn't draw much audience.
你描述的所有这些以前在公共广播上播放的东西，都没有吸引太多的观众。
Well, I think there's going to have to be room for things that don't draw much audience. And I think they would draw much considerable audience if they were done right.
嗯，我认为必须有空间容纳那些没有吸引太多观众的东西。而且我认为如果做得对，它们会吸引相当多的观众。
[MUSIC - "CAR SONG" BY ELASTICA]
[音乐 - ELASTICA的《汽车之歌》（CAR SONG）]
Act Four, Fiascoes as a Force for Good. George Clooney, Jennifer Aniston, Shannon Dougherty, Jodie Foster, Alicia Silverstone, Brad Pitt, Keanu Reeves, Sharon Stone, and John Travolta. Also, George Burns, Bob Hope, Gene Kelly, Gena Rowlands. Also, Quentin Tarantino, John Waters, Nora Ephron, Joel Schumacher. Margy Rochlin has interviewed all these people. She does big magazine feature stories for big magazines. But the very, very first big feature assignment she was actually sent out on by a publication was in 1982. The Los Angeles Reader sent out a very nervous, very youthful Margy Rochlin to interview Moon Unit Zappa, daughter of Frank, who had consented to her second interview ever after the release of her runaway hit song, "Valley Girl."
第四幕，惨败作为一种向善力量。乔治·克鲁尼（George Clooney）、詹妮弗·安妮斯顿（Jennifer Aniston）、香农·多赫蒂（Shannon Dougherty）、朱迪·福斯特（Jodie Foster）、艾丽西亚·希尔维斯通（Alicia Silverstone）、布拉德·皮特（Brad Pitt）、基努·里维斯（Keanu Reeves）、莎朗·斯通（Sharon Stone）和约翰·特拉沃尔塔（John Travolta）。还有乔治·伯恩斯（George Burns）、鲍勃·霍普（Bob Hope）、吉恩·凯利（Gene Kelly）、吉娜·罗兰兹（Gena Rowlands）。还有昆汀·塔伦蒂诺（Quentin Tarantino）、约翰·沃特斯（John Waters）、诺拉·艾芙隆（Nora Ephron）、乔尔·舒马赫（Joel Schumacher）。玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）采访过所有这些人。她为大杂志做大型杂志专题报道。但出版物实际上派她去执行的第一个非常、非常大的专题任务是在1982年。《洛杉矶读者》派出了一个非常紧张、非常年轻的玛吉·罗克林去采访弗兰克·扎帕（Frank Zappa）的女儿月球单元·扎帕（Moon Unit Zappa），她在她那首逃跑式的热门歌曲《山谷女孩》（Valley Girl）发行后，同意接受她的第二次采访。
In this little bit that she does on the song, she's using a lot of this language, this sort of Valspeak that no one had never heard before. And it was considered really exotic. And so I was from the Valley, so I was sent to go talk to her.
在这段她做的歌曲中，她使用了很多这种语言，这种没人听过的所谓“山谷方言（Valspeak）”。它被认为真的很异国情调。所以我来自山谷，所以我被派去和她谈话。
She was one of your people. Speak to her in your secret, private argot.
她是你们的人之一。用你们秘密、私人的行话与她交谈。
Exactly. And of course, what is so touching to me is that I totally bought that. "You're right. I'm the right person for the job. I'm going to go speak to her in the Valley language, and we will bond."
完全正确。当然，让我感动的是，我完全买账了。“你是对的。我是做这份工作的合适人选。我要去用山谷语言和她交谈，我们会建立联系。”
So you get there, and you're a bit nervous. And the pressure is on, which is, of course, the setting for a possible triumph or a possible fiasco.
所以你到了那里，你有点紧张。压力很大，这当然是可能取得胜利或可能造成惨败的环境。
Right.
对。
And what happens next?
接下来发生了什么？
Well, what I noticed was it was a tense situation. I just didn't feel like it was going very well. And the mother was sort of hovering.
嗯，我注意到情况很紧张。我只是觉得进行得不太顺利。母亲有点徘徊。
Right. Well, we have a recording of it, because you had a tape recorder rolling during this.
对。嗯，我们有一份录音，因为你在采访时录音机在转。
Yes.
是的。
What are some other hangouts in the Valley, besides the Galleria?
除了画廊（Galleria），山谷里还有什么其他常去的地方？
Bowling alleys with big arcades are very popular.
带大型拱廊的保龄球馆非常受欢迎。
Like what?
比如什么？
Oh, I'm trying-- at this point, I'm sort of at that rock bottom level that everyone can get at in an interview, where you're just saying, "What's your favorite color?" And she's trying to help me along.
噢，我正试图——在这一点上，我处于每个人在采访中都能达到的那种岩石底部水平，你只是说，“你最喜欢的颜色是什么？”而她正试图帮我一把。
Kirkwood's is gone.
柯克伍德（Kirkwood's）不见了。
It's now the sports center--
现在是体育中心——
Oh, but it's the same thing?
噢，但还是一样的东西？
Yeah, it's still very popular--
是的，它仍然非常受欢迎——
So we're seated in the den. And the mother made me coffee. But I was too nervous to drink it. But I sort of kept staring it, and she kept staring at it. And I felt like it was pretty important that, at some point, I'd better drain that coffee cup. And so what happened was, Moon told me a joke. And I didn't see the joke coming. And right before she told me the joke, I had taken a big swig of the coffee, which was now cold. And when she told me the joke, I burst out laughing. And I started to choke. And so I pressed my lips together, so I didn't spit it out. I didn't want to do a spit-take. And the coffee came shooting out my nose.
所以我们坐在书房里。母亲给我做了咖啡。但我太紧张了，没敢喝。但我只是盯着它，她也一直盯着它。我觉得在某个点上，我最好喝掉那个咖啡杯里的东西，这很重要。所以发生的事情是，月球给我讲了一个笑话。我没预料到这个笑话。就在她讲笑话之前，我大喝了一口咖啡，现在已经凉了。当她讲那个笑话时，我忍不住笑了。我开始窒息。所以我抿紧嘴唇，没有把它吐出来。我不想做那种“吐出”的动作。咖啡从我的鼻子里喷了出来。
Shooting out your nose?
从鼻子里喷出来？
Shooting right out my nose.
直接从我的鼻子里喷出来。
[COUGHING]
[咳嗽]
Are you OK? Get your hands up.
你没事吧？把手举起来。
And I was really embarrassed. But I couldn't breathe. At the same time, I was choking. And I jumped up. And I sort of started running around the room, knocking things over. And I think that they didn't know what was going on. But the mother began chasing me.
我真的很尴尬。但我无法呼吸。与此同时，我窒息了。我跳了起来。我开始在房间里跑来跑去，撞倒东西。我想他们不知道发生了什么。但母亲开始追我。
She began chasing you?
她开始追你？
She began chasing me, because I was sort of running from corner to corner, trying to catch my breath. And she began chasing me. And at a certain point, she got behind me, and she gave me the Heimlich maneuver.
她开始追我，因为我当时在房间里跑来跑去，试图吸口气。她开始追我。在某个点上，她到了我身后，对我实施了海姆立克急救法。
Put your arms up. No, really. Seriously. OK?
把手臂举起来。不，真的。严肃点。好的？
Let's do the Heimlich maneuver.
我们做海姆立克急救法。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[混合声音]
Well, I've been in the news business-- I've been a reporter for 20 years. And nobody has ever given me the Heimlich maneuver while I've been on a story.
嗯，我在新闻界呆过——我做记者20年了。在我做报道时，从来没有人对我实施过海姆立克急救法。
Well, I always say that it's a benchmark. It's a very low benchmark. And I can do any interview, I can get thrown off a set, I can be cursed out by the subject. But I can leave and get in the car. And I can drive home and think, I didn't blow coffee out my nose.
嗯，我总是说这是一个基准。这是一个非常低的基准。我可以做任何采访，我可以被赶出片场，我可以被采访对象诅咒。但我可以离开并上车。我可以开车回家并想，我没把咖啡从鼻子里喷出来。
Now, what happened after that?
现在，那之后发生了什么？
It was sort of like we had all been in an earthquake together. And all of the nervousness left the room. And suddenly, we were three gals, just chatting. And I remember that I sort of hugged them both when I left.
感觉就像我们都经历了一场地震。所有的紧张感都从房间里消失了。突然间，我们成了三个正在聊天的女孩。我记得我离开时拥抱了她们两个。
Wow.
哇。
They were now my friends.
她们现在是我的朋友了。
It's interesting, because one of our criteria for a fiasco is that all social order, the normal social structure, breaks down. And literally, that's what happens here. The normal interview stops. And the social structure of the moment completely changes. The mom gives you the Heimlich maneuver. And then, suddenly, it stops feeling like an interview.
这很有趣，因为我们惨败的标准之一是所有的社会秩序、正常的社会结构崩溃。字面上，这里发生的就是这种情况。正常的采访停止了。那一刻的社会结构完全改变了。妈妈给了你海姆立克急救法。然后，突然之间，它感觉不像是一个采访了。
Yeah. And I have to say that it was a very embarrassing experience, and it completely made me feel close to them. It was so interesting. When Moon's father died a while ago, I bumped into her somewhere, and we both burst into tears. I really felt like a little sister of mine had had a loss. And the starting point was--
是的。我不得不说，这是一次非常尴尬的经历，它完全让我觉得和她们很亲近。这太有趣了。当月球的父亲前段时间去世时，我在某个地方碰到了她，我们都哭了出来。我真的觉得我的一个小妹妹遭遇了损失。而起点是——
That moment.
那一刻。
--that moment.
——那一刻。
To me, the thing about it that's useful is that it shows the useful purpose of a fiasco. That is, when social order breaks down, that could be a force not just for chaos and for entropy and for evil, but, in fact, that could be a force for good.
对我来说，关于它有用的地方是，它显示了惨败的有用目的。也就是说，当社会秩序崩溃时，那可能不仅是混乱、熵和邪恶的力量，事实上，那可能是一种向善的力量。
Right.
对。
It can bring people together.
它可以把人们聚在一起。
Right. It was actually this huge success to me. I'd never been sent out under these kind of certain circumstances before. And I remember, we beat the local paper. The Herald Examiner followed us a week later. And so we had the first story. And it was sort of considered the definitive one, because we had this glossary of terms that I had made or put together--
对。对我来说，这实际上是一个巨大的成功。我以前从来没有在这种特定情况下被派出来过。我记得，我们打败了当地报纸。《先驱考察家报》（Herald Examiner）一周后跟进。所以我们有了第一篇报道。它被认为是权威的一篇，因为我们有我制作或汇编的术语表——
Of Valleyspeak terms.
关于山谷方言术语的。
Of Valleyspeak terms. And then it was syndicated.
关于山谷方言术语的。然后它被联合起来了。
And most of the quotable stuff that you ended up using in your story happened after the incident?
你在故事中最终使用的大部分可引用内容都发生在事件之后？
Yeah.
是的。
Happened after squirting the coffee through your nose.
发生在把咖啡从鼻子喷出来之后。
Right, exactly. Exactly. It's a technique I don't suggest anyone try. For years afterwards, Moon would send me postcards. And on the postcard somewhere would be a picture of a nose, and there would be liquid coming out of it, sort of like my logo.
对，完全正确。完全正确。这是一种我不建议任何人尝试的技术。在那之后的几年里，月球会寄明信片给我。明信片上的某个地方会有一张鼻子的照片，会有液体从里面出来，有点像我的标志。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Paul Tough, Alix Spiegel, and Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Contributing editors for this show, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from [? Laura Doggett, ?] Seth Lind, and Cathy Hoang. Musical help from Mr. John Connors.
好吧，我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和我自己以及保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）制作。伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）管理我们的网站。本节目的特约编辑，杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。制作帮助来自[？劳拉·多格特（Laura Doggett），？]赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）和凯茜·黄（Cathy Hoang）。约翰·康纳斯（John Connors）先生提供音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our story about Car Talk and this whole program first aired in 1997. Wisconsin Public Radio is now 27 stations. Back then, we could barely get on the air in Wisconsin.
我们关于《卡车谈话》的故事和整个节目首次播出于1997年。威斯康星州公共广播电台现在有27个电台。那时，我们在威斯康星州几乎无法播出。
You know, our show isn't on-- we're on in Milwaukee, but the state network hasn't picked us up yet. Somehow, I don't think this is going to help.
你知道，我们的节目没有上——我们在密尔沃基播出，但州网络还没有接纳我们。不知何故，我不认为这会有所帮助。
No, this won't help.
不，这不会有帮助。
No, I don't think this is going to help very much, either.
不，我不认为这会有多大帮助。
Maybe send a copy of it to Senator Wirch. He might be interested.
也许发一份给沃奇参议员。他可能会感兴趣。
If you want a copy of our program, whether you're a state senator in Wisconsin or not, visit our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where we now have a free weekly podcast, plus all our old shows. You can get those at the iTunes store, as well. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想要我们节目的副本，无论你是不是威斯康星州的州参议员，访问我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org，我们现在那里有一个免费的每周播客，加上我们所有的旧节目。你也可以在iTunes商店里获取那些。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助信用]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who explains the quality of our program this way.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他这样解释我们节目的质量。
You know, they just don't make those hooks like they used to.
你知道，他们就是不再像以前那样制造钩子了。
No, they don't. No, they don't. I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
不，他们没有。不，他们没有。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。